Louis, no no no no. You do not trim these hedges from top to bottom but from bottom to top.
As we've discussed.
Many times.
Alright I'll trim the bushes myself.
And you can cut the grass.
You cut the grass yesterday.
Yes.
what can I do for you, Ms Lauler?
I request a formal introduction
come with me
are you firing me?
you should be so lucky
Ms Sherman, the thought of leaving my obituary to chance is completely unreasonable to me
Well, I am the obituary writer. So, when the time comes, I will be writing your obituary.
I want you to write it now.
Huh
Here's the names of a few hundred people
My name is Anne Sherman, I'm from the Bristol Gazette
I'd like to talk to you about Harriet Lauler.
Now, the deceased should be loved by their families
There's an ex husband
He's a jackass
As I live and breathe
Well from the looks of it I'm not sure you do.
The deceased must have touched someone's life
I hated her.
So much.
If I want your opinion, I will give it to you.
That's what she told me. I was her gynaecologist.
Is there just one thing you could say about her that's nice?
If she were dead, that would be nice.
How's that?
Wow. She puts the bitch in obituary.
How grossly I overestimated your talent as a writer.
The problem isn't with my writing
That was just me writing about your life.
My life is not over, yet.
You are going to help shape a legacy.
We have to find a youth to mould
And that will be the person whose life I touch.
You got busted for drunk driving, didn't you?
Excuse me?
You're white, and you're here.
When I was a kid, I loved the radio
I'd like a job as a disk jockey.
And what kind of music would you play?
The right question would be, what would I play after I played the kinks?
And who is this?
It's my intern.
Waddup!
Did I just lose my job to a hundred year old woman?
This is Harriet Lauler saying 'please don't have a nice day'.
I don't know if I can write your obituary.
I'm just not ready to close this chapter of my life.
Have a day that matters. Have a day that's true.
Punch it.
Have a day that means something.
Harriet, you're a piece of work.
I am who I am.